[Musique]
bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous pour
audition publique en direct notre rendez
vous du lundi soir
public sénat lcp le figaro live une
heure de débat de confrontation
d'interviews avec notre invité
aujourd'hui laurent berger bonjour vous
élancer vers général de la cfdt en plein
dans l'actualité on va y revenir
évidemment on va retrouver dans quelques
instants mes consoeurs des chaînes
parlementaires puis deux parlementaires
qui vont vous interroger une sénatrice
et un député et puis très ardue figaro
qui viendra en fin d'émission vous dire
un peu ce qu'il a ressenti de votre
audition publique et puis d'autres
questions qui se posent plus celles des
téléspectateurs ou des internautes qui
peuvent nous envoyer leurs
interrogations que je transmettrai au
fur et à mesure dans la mesure du
possible sur figurera live je disais
vous êtes dans l'actualité parce que il
y a eu déjà une intrusion violente
c'est comme ça que vous l'avez qualifié
en fin de semaine dernière au siège de
la cdt ça a recommencé ce matin ou là ce
sont des anti réforme des retraites qui
sont allés au siège de la cfdt qui ont
coupé le courant
c'est ça et qui se revendique de la cgt
énergie de france d'abord qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé est ce qu'il ya eu des
violences cette fois est ce qu'il ya eu
des dégâts matériels ont ce matin c'est
une quinzaine de personnes cagoulés et
habillés en noir qui ont pénétré dans
l'entrée de la cfdt qui se sont
certaines d'entre elles se sont
faufiler entre guillemets dans la trappe
edf qui existent et ont coupé
l'électricité
ça a duré quelques minutes une quinzaine
de milles de tous mais avec pour les
personnes de l'accueil pour les
personnes qui passaient situation assez
impressionnante
vous allez porter plainte vous l'avez
dit mais cette fois vous savez qui c'est
puisque c'est signé cgt énergie
ile-de-france donc vous allez porter
plainte contre ce syndicat précisément
on va porter plainte contre les
personnes qui ce matin nous n'avons pas
identifié ont accompli cette action des
plaintes individuelles pas contre le
syndicat entre x puisqu'ils étaient
cagoulés oui mais ça aurait pu tout
aussi contre deux syndicats je suis pas
je suis pas je suis pas avocat donc ce
n'est pas moi qui va arriver
définir comment va le faire ce qui est
sûr c'est que je veux condamner cette
action ça suffit vendredi dernier une
intrusion avec des crachats des
violences verbales et physiques des
insultes ce matin une intrusion dans nos
locaux depuis quinze personnes cagoulées
qui coupent l'électricité et vous
craignez que ça se répète j'espère pas
mais les surprises que vous craignez que
ça se répète
en tout cas je trouve que ce climat est
insupportable je le répète nous sommes
dans une démocratie
nous ne pensons pas tous la même chose
c'est bien normal dans une démocratie il
y a plusieurs organisations syndicales
dans ce pays
elles portent pas tout exactement la
même appréciation sur la période
mais la cfdt est légitime elle doit être
respectée comme elle respecte l'ensemble
des autres organisations je disais c'est
un set est signée revendiquer j'allais
dire par cgt énergie de france vous
allez en parler à philippe martinez dû
dire il est temps de tenir vos troupes
j'ai déjà eu et philippe martinât risée
de la presse avant la semaine depuis ce
matin et philippe martinez à titre
personnel m'a dit qu'il condamnait et je
le crois
comme il avait appelé vendredi pour dire
qu'il condamne à l'action qui a été mené
mais est-ce qu'il doit tenir ses troupes
écoutez moi ce qui m'intéresse dans
cette situation c'est que philippe
martinez et pris l'initiative d'appeler
vendredi je les saisies de ce qui
s'était passé ce matin et il est sans
ambiguïté à titre personnel pour me dire
qu'ils condamnent et bien je vais pas
aller mimi c'est ensuite dans la gestion
de son organisation
me permettrais pas de le faire mais en
tout cas je le dit philippe martinez a
condamné cette action on va cueillir
maintenant thème traduit de public sénat
et brigitte boucher de lcp
une poignée de questions
oui justement pas en revenir à cette
intrusion de ce matin la cgt énergie ile
de france dans ses tracts vous accuse
je le cite de faire de la collaboration
de classe et de négocier les couleurs et
les formes de nos futures chaînes
comment est-ce que vous réagissez à ces
mots à ces attaques de la part d'un
autre syndicat francis lun souligné
d'abord je pourrais juste les invités à
faire un peu de un peu de renouvellement
de leur formule c'est à peu près les
mêmes formules qui sont employés depuis
30 ans à l'égard de la cfdt lors de
différents du différents épisodes mais
ceci mis à part
écoutez je trouve ça inacceptable je
vais vous dire franchement j'en ai assez
des insultes à céder infecte yves
discutons sur le fond nous sommes en
désaccord
peut-être que tous les uns n'ont pas
totalement raison et les autres
totalement tort division avec le
gouvernement traduit la wka en quoi en
quoi ça veut dire que nous sur cette
réforme des retraites
nous avons fait une analyse critique
nous continuons de le faire il ya des
points qui ne vont pas et nous
continuons de le dire nous avons aussi
revendiquer la fin de l'âge pivot dans
ce projet doit il ne sera pas dans le
projet de loi qui est présenté au
conseil des think tanks sur le foot donc
moi si vous voulez je vais pas passer
mon temps à commenter des gens qui se
réclament à eux seuls détenteurs des
intérêts des travailleurs de je ne sais
quelle valeur moi je sais que je sais
c'est que mes interlocuteurs je les
respecte et je les insulte pas brillé
que vous suscitez quand même beaucoup de
critiques de la part de ceux qui tuent
vous en veulent qui sont introduits chez
vous aujourd'hui qu'ils étaient chez
vous vendredi ils vous accusent de
négocier avec le patronat
finalement d'être complices de ceux de
ce gouvernement presque un jaune
finalement est ce que vous vous
ressentez parfois que certains peuvent
vous prendre pour un traître
donc c'est d'abord il faut frais je me
méfie beaucoup du relativisme parce
qu'on tout ça est présenté comme si ce
film finalement ce serait quelque chose
d'assez normal c'est pas normal
les insultes c'est pas normal dans un
pays dans une démocratie deuxièmement
vous savez la définition de traite ce
que ça veut dire c'est lorsqu'on portait
quelque chose et qu'on n'est pas allé au
bout et qu'on a finalement
on n'a pas été au bout de son idée qu'on
a indiqué on a abdiqué
la cfdt sur cette réforme des retraites
elle a été très clair vous étiez des
rouleaux un système universel nous
voulons un système universel des
retraites
nous voulons un système des retraites
plus juste nous l'avons toujours dit en
quoi serions nous traite à ce que nous
avons dit en rien si la valeur étalon du
syndicalisme c'est ce que portent ces
personnes et je parle pas de leur
organisation je parle de ces personnes
si c'est ce qu'elle porte en quoi ils
sont en quoi ils ont le droit de ceux
trop pour proclamer défenseurs des
travailleurs s'est pas immiscé personnel
font partie d'un syndicat
irvine vendredi uni je ne sais pas je ne
sais pas on dit je ne sais pas
aujourd'hui c'est revendiquer et bien je
le dis pour cela pour cela et je ne mets
pas tout
la cgt dans le même sac je le dis pour
cela je trouve que c'est scandaleux et
je n'ai pas de leçon de s'animer risque
pas d'être dans un syndicat non non je
dis pas ça je dis que elles n'ont pas de
deux et puis ça va il ya un autre
élément qui est important pour moi c'est
la confiance qu'on obtient des
travailleurs
la cfdt elle est devenue malgré ses
traîtrises en permanence soit disant
avec ce minéral est devenu non elle est
devenue première organisation syndicale
mme toutes confondues
et ça c'est des travailleurs qu'on voter
alors soit les travailleurs sont les
idiots pour ces personnes soient ils
veulent un syndicat qui apportent des
rezzous la saisie des travailleurs a
changé aussi peut-être tam
oui laurent berger le monde aujourd'hui
pointe du doigt le fait que ce qui vous
conseillent sont ceux qui conseillait
hier emmanuel macron notamment pendant
sa campagne
les économistes jean pisani ferry
philippe aghion est-ce que ça ça sème le
doute nous mais ces économistes comme
d'autres comme beaucoup d'autres la cfdt
a cette particularité qu'il entretient
des liens avec le monde intellectuel
donc ces économistes dans l'article je
crois qu'il est cité d'autres
économistes qui sont pas soupçonnable
oui enfin font maintenant mais eric
heyer de l'ofce les mains trop liste
j'entends bien mais
le programme des séances et finir il est
dit que il nous conseille c'est une
c'est pas vrai il y dit qu'on s'est
rencontrés après on a oui on les
rencontre comme on rencontre d'autres
intellectuels ils vont pas d'adversaire
unis est ce qu ils vont pas vous
conseiller si en propre nous conseiller
dans les négociations nous par contre
qu'on consulte tout un tas de dea
d'économie ce n'est pas que des
économistes des pertes des personnes qui
sont spécialistes du travail stars comme
dans cette discussion sur les retraites
comme sur d'autres sujets oui oui juste
une idée reçue avant de percer est ce
que vous craignez d'être débordés par
des par des mouvements violents est ce
que vous personnellement vous êtes
menacés et est ce que vous sentez
attaqué non mais que les militants
aujourd'hui vous quand les ans en plus
moi personnellement je pas envie de
répondre c'est pas très important
oui je sais pas qui c'est pas le climat
le plus sécurisant qu'on ait connu mais
aujourd'hui une union départementale à
brest a eu un collage sauvage avec des
propos insultants et c'est celle adoptée
la troisième c'était le cas à perpignan
ça a été le cas
à quand des militants dans les
entreprises sont malmenés par ce que il
serait soit disant aux traîtres ou je ne
sais quoi il faut que ça cesse et où je
dis juste il faut que ça cesse vous
vivez en fait ce qu'ont vécu les députés
macro nist avec leur permanence non mais
arrêtez
non mais je dis ça parce que je veux
dire c'est le scellier ça fait cinq
minutes que vous êtes en train de faire
passer non mais ça fait cinq minutes que
vous êtes en train de laisser croire que
ce que fait que le l'action qu'ils
mènent la cfdt se serait finalement en
lien avec l'action du gouvernement
non je vous le dis pas du tout pas du
tout on est un acquis en juin dès
vendredi
c'est ce que n'ont cessé ce que vivent
je crois toute personne dans une
démocratie qui essaye d'avoir un
discours un peu modérer essais et je
crois que la cfdt elle dérange je vais
vous dire un certain nombre de gens
parce qu on a aussi été attaqué par dans
des propos par l'extrême droite
madame le pen nous a traité d'idiot
utile et c'est comme d'ailleurs les
réponses des entraîneurs oui eh bien je
vais vous le dire
j'en ai assez assez que il s'occupe de
faire des propositions de mener ce qui
leur semble bon et nous le fait
et jusqu'à preuve du contraire baril
c'est sur ce dossier oui l'unsa ratp
demande aujourd'hui la suspension de la
grève
changer les modalités du mouvement qu'en
est il de la cfdt cheminots
la cfdt cheminots elle est encore dans
des discussions au sein de l'entreprise
et laurent grève elle est oui enfin elle
est là elle fait des mouvements
sporadiques
elle n'est pas en grève en continu
d'accord mais elle est toujours dans le
mouvement elle et elle elle est
aujourd'hui elle a signé un accord
vendredi dans la branche et elle essaye
ou encore de mme négociation dans
l'entreprise vous souhaitez qu'elle
arrête cette grève avec un lien avec
elle en permanence
elle est plus vraiment dans un mouvement
de grève allait plutôt dans des
mouvements de mobilisation journalier la
prochaine étant je crois à la semaine
prochaine mais elle n'est pas
aujourd'hui en désaccord avec la cfdt
avec la confédération sur la réforme
systémique et le fait qui est débordée
par cette entreprise un vrai nom
brigitte
finalement s'il avait pas eu ces grèves
est ce que vous auriez obtenu autant est
ce que vous auriez obtenu le retrait par
exemple de l'âge pivot tout a contribué
personnes ces personnes à cfdt contribue
que tout cela serait le seul fait de la
cfdt c'est le tout ce qui à un moment
donné on dit que la sljo était une
mesure injuste aveugle qu'on contribue à
le faire donc y compris ceux qui ont
permis sa ba oui d'ailleurs sécurité
dans la rue dont bien sûr on s'en doute
mais c'est sait très bien que le
syndicalisme il est capable de démontrer
que par différents moyens il est capable
d'obtenir des résultats là je puis vous
justement c'était votre ligne rouge il a
été retiré mais demeure dans le texte
l'âge des ti libre c'est un petit peu
l'âge pivot mais à long terme
pourquoi ça ne vous fâche plus pourquoi
ça ce n'est pas une mais vous avez tort
c'est assez agaçant je vais vous le dire
franchement cette façon de penser à ma
place l'âge l'âge pivot c'était dès 2022
vous savez pourquoi on est en colère
parce que dès 2022 et en 2023 et en 2024
et j'en ai travaillé quatre mois huit
mois un an supplémentaire et jusqu'à
deux ans trois ans après ça c'était
extrêmement concret très rapidement
c'était donc la ctr mme elham
n'envisager que je vais finir jeu
c'était inacceptable parce que ça
s'appliquait à des gens qui avaient la
carrière complète et qu'ils allaient se
retrouver très vite très très vite alors
qu'on leur avait dit vous êtes à cinq
ans de la retraite vous n'allez pas être
concerné très vite d'oubli j'ai
travaillé jeudi jusqu'à deux ans c'est
la même chose mais moins maintenant
l'âge d'équilibré on continue de dire
que dans un système de retraite par
points ça ne fait pas sens ce qui fait
sens dans un système de retraite par
points c'est la question de la prise en
compte des specs des carrières
individuelles et donc on continue de
dire que c'est pas une bonne mesure
d'opérer la lâche mais où est ce que
vous l'avez leur usage et qui l'aimé
mais n'a dans l'est dans les
consultations dans les discussions par
le moins que c'est la cvt le fera valoir
que l'âge d'équilibré douadi cependant
un système
universel n'a pas lieu d'être il faudra
supprimer l'âge des clips qui
aujourd'hui est donc cet été continue de
dire qu'elle n'est pas d'accord avec
l'âge des kills ou es ce que vous avez
vu l inverse non mais c'est pourquoi
vous avez pas vu ma signature en bas du
corps et du pré ministre nous ce qu'on a
accepté cette rentrée dans une démarche
qui est celle de la conférence de
financement pour le reste nous allons
faire notre travail pour que sur la
pénibilité sur l'âge utiliser ce système
ce musée est ce que vous êtes d'accord
pour dire qu'il faudra travailler plus
longtemps et c'est déjà le cas mais oui
je sais il s'agit de plus en plus
d'abord madame la loi touraine de 2013
elle prévoit qu on augmente la durée de
trimestre le nombre de trimestres
jusqu'en 2035
donc pour arrêter de penser qu'on serait
dans une situation statique
après est-ce qu'il faudra travailler
plus longtemps mais j'ai envie de vous
dire pas tout le monde
pas tout le monde et moi ce qui m'a
fâché dans l'âge pivot c'est que dans
l'est pas tout le monde
ben il n'y avait pas ça et notamment il
y avait tous les travailleurs de
l'agroalimentaire du bâtiment des
services des commerces de du monde
hospitalier etc qui étaient concernés
comme les autres certains devront
travailler plus longtemps
assoc de toute façon déjà dans le
système actuel chacun à son âge du taux
plein comme on dit à des âges différents
vous vous vous et moi on partira pas on
les reverra pas aux ménages
parce que si on veut partir à taux plein
ça dépend de comment on a travaillé à
quel âge on a commencé comment s'est
passée la durée de la génération a
justement la génération 90 kg à une
étude d'impact qui a été dévoilé dans
ces derniers jours elle évoque un âge
dati libre à 67 ans pour que le système
soit équilibré et sa peau ses 67 ans
pour la génération 80 est ce que pour
vous cet âge là pour cette génération là
c'est acceptable non mais non c'est vrai
j'avais porté cette idée mais sauf que
c'est dans l'étude d'impact mais non
c'est à graffer justement mais mais mais
pourquoi vous voulez voir de moi ce soir
le défendeur le défenseur
parlementaire oui mais un débat
parlementaire
il y aura d'abord la conférence de
financement il n'est pas prévu
comment vous voulez un accord avec les
syndicats dans une conférence de
financement si ça peut pas s'appeler un
accord dans la conférence de financement
et les organismes syndicats les harkis
sont patronales et l'état donc il y aura
je sais pas a relevé de conclusion un
consensus on appelle ça comme on veut
mais ce qui est sûr c'est que nous on
veut discuter de du financement du
régime des retraites à court moyen et
long terme à moyen et long terme
c'était juste équilibre n'a pas sens
d'autant plus quand on la sauce quand on
associe pas avec la question de la
pénibilité l'aménagement des fins de
carrière de la prise en compte de la
meilleure prise en compte des aléas de
carrière liées au chômage et à donc
voilà on peut contribuer à aménager
améliorer ce texte y compris c'est le
travail qu'on a entrepris aujourd'hui
avec les parlementaires c'est par
exemple en auvergne rhône-alpes
aujourd'hui il rend compte de 13
parlementaires pour discuter avec eux de
ce que veut la cfdt dans ce système les
républicains ont totalement tort quand
ils disent qu'on va vers une baisse des
pensions pour équilibrer financièrement
le système de retraite oui longtemps que
je crois d'ailleurs le système attendons
plus les 26 avait des certitudes
monsieur de théziers surtout les
certitudes vous savez je vais vous
répondre mais les certitudes dans le
domaine des retraites
moi j'entends des choses autour de
comment ça se passera d'un deuxième
moitié du xxième siècle
mais imaginons rien ne change sur les
retraites on garde ce système actuel qui
a fait ses preuves
quelqu'un plein d'inégalités qui peut
dire comment ça se passera un deuxième
moitié du xxième siècle personne pour
les l'accord diverses invite donc la
baisse des pensions elle est donc la
baisse est comme une diva pas
inéluctable le système de soutien compte
des meilleures années mais ça dépend de
qui on parle
c'est un système plus redistributif un
système universel d'ailleurs c'est pour
ça que la cfdt le porte c'est pas par
hasard c'est pas par volonté de
changement mené par je ne sais quelle
motivation c'est que c'est un système
plus redistributif ça veut dire quoi qui
contribuent davantage à améliorer les
pensions de ceux qui aujourd'hui sont le
plus sanctionné par le système c'est à
dire les personnes qui ont des carrières
linéaires des personnes
subissent beaucoup de précarité des
personnes qui subissent du temps partiel
c'est pour ça qu'on veut ce système
universel pour davantage réparer les
inégalités table donc tout n'est pas
évidemment fixé c'est pas la réforme que
la cfdt souhaite mais essayer de se
projeter dans la deuxième partie du 21e
siècle
avec ce système là comme avec le 6ème
anniversaire ce que le rapport du cor en
disant cela conseil d'orienter ce pas le
rapport vous savez imaginons ce
gouvernement tue pas s'il va y arriver
mais il dit que l'objectif c'est 7% de
chômage à la fin du quinquennat
vous avez des doutes sur le fait qu'il y
arrive en tout cas c'est ce est il
faudra regarder la qualité de l'emploi
aussi hein c'est pas trop précaire mais
imaginons qu'on ne soit 7% de chômage
ces 8 milliards d'excédents pour
l'unedic voyez ce que je veux dire c'est
que la meilleure manière d'améliorer la
question du financement des retraites
c'est d'améliorer la situation de
l'emploi comme est ce que vous craignez
que cette réforme que les projets de loi
soit la porte ouverte à la
capitalisation il ya des articles dans
le texte est bien qui sème le doute
le doute je là encore je ne crois pas
qu'un régime universel sur le projet de
loi on a fait une analyse critique il ya
des sujets sur lesquels on veut revenir
mais sûre je ne crois pas que la
capitalisation
il ya plus de risques aujourd'hui que
dans le système actuel
parce que moi j'adore ces moments c'est
à travers elle est pas l'occasion pour
le gouvernement d'appuyer non pour toi
je crois pas et il faudra en pire pas
les choses non là qui sont moi je crois
que sur les retraites il faut consolider
le système par répartition laquelle
hervé gergoy
ça veut dire qu'il faut un bon niveau de
pension et sur la capitalisation mais
c'est la capitalisation ça peut être que
autres en plus mais qu'on arrête
l'hypocrisie
parce que la capitalisation ça existe ça
s'appelle comment si on est dans le
système le plus verte ça s'appelle le
plan d'épargné retraite collectif qui se
négocie dans les entreprises
si on est dans le système le plus
individualisé et on peut pas se dire que
ça n'existe pas ça s'appelle l'assurance
maladie la sueur pardon l'assurance vie
c'est ça que c'est comme ça que l'on
vous souhaitez moi une façon aille plus
loin
je souhaite à qui son souhait qu'on
maintienne un système de retraite par
répartition qui permet de
des niveaux de pension qui permette de
vivre dignement et vous savez c'est pour
ça qu'on se bat pour le minimum
contributif
c'est pour ça que nous dit que le
minimum de contributif quand vous avez
accompli votre carrière vous pourriez
vous devriez pas avoir moins de 100 % du
smic est aujourd'hui le gouvernement
nous dit 85% nous parmi les choses qu'on
va pousser dans les semaines à venir
c'est d'aller beaucoup plus loin 85 en
2010 cette réforme ouvre la porte au
fonds de pension c'est ce que claudius
nous demande sur figaro live vous dit
non c'est pas vrai pas plus que le
système actuel il ya un point important
dans les négociations que vous menez
c'est la pénibilité dans cette réforme
des retraites est ce que vous souhaitez
que les quatre critères qui ont été
supprimés soit réintroduit supprimé en
2017 ou est-ce que vous souhaitez même
qu' il soit élargi ses critères de
pénibilité
nous on souhaite que ces critères
pénibilité qui concerne des centaines de
milliers de personnes que j'ai cités
tout à l'heure le bâtiment l'e commerce
des services les services
l'agroalimentaire la métallurgie
l'industrie ils soient pris en compte
c'est à dire que expliquez-moi rétabli
dont pour certains oui rétabli en tout
cas ils permettent d'avoir une
compensations en termes de départ
anticipé à la retraite mais également en
termes de reconversion s'il a bien
sprinté difficilement facile mais alors
si le problème est juste de mesure et
individuellement
faisons-le ou par branches décidant par
branches quand même on est dans un
système aujourd'hui ou si vous êtes
déménageurs vous n'étiez pas concerné
par le comte pénibilité qui peut
dignement dire que quelqu'un qui fait
les déménageurs n'est pas concernée par
des port de charges lourdes
est-ce qu'il faut il faut et l'argent
donc les critères de non il faut que les
quatre critères qui sont les gestes et
postures le port de charges nous les
jeunes tarnosiens objets tara et bien
soit pris en compte pour compenser des
départs anticipés 80 seulement celle
reliant secrétaire il ya le risque
chimique dedans donc ça devrait dans les
cadres il faut qu' il faut qu'on ces
quatre-là sassou suffit à quoi vous
pensez
je sais pas belle et riscle par exemple
a mis les risques psychosociaux je vais
vous dire c'est que ça s'anticipe ça se
prévient et que moi je ne suis pas pour
faire payer à la retraite ce qu'on peut
faire pendant le travail et donc sur les
sur ces tous ces risques psychosociaux
c'est pas normal qu'une personne souffre
psychologiquement au travail
ça veut dire qu'on n'a pas prévenu et
donc c'est aussi l'autre versant de ce
qu'on veut pousser aujourd'hui dans
cette année 2020 c'est une vraie
discussion sur la qualité de vie au
travail ça fait pas partie de la réforme
c'est vraiment la terre depuis dit
satisfait sister établissent à vous
savez ça nous suffit si on arrive à les
redresser
je sais que ce mot peut paraître bizarre
mais ce sera une belle victoire pour les
travailleurs concernés ah ben oui vous
avez commencé à parler tout à l'heure de
la conférence de finances moi ce que
vous pouvez nous en dire plus
combien de réunions à partir de quand
comment ça va s'organiser
bah non je peux pas vous en dire que
c'est pas moi le premier ministre de ce
pays n'en suis sur la méthode non j'ai
engagé dans sa conférence vous ce que
veut la cfdt c'est que cette conférence
de financement elle s'occupe aussi du
financement des retraites à moyen et
long terme et donc qu'on ait enfin des
chiffres sur les besoins de financement
à court moyen et long terme donc le
premier élément pour nous ce sera des
chiffres qui pourront être expertisés et
sur lesquels on se mettra d'accord il
pour l'instant soit les banderilles aux
prix bas pour l'instant on s'est pas
totalement
combien va coûter telles mesures etc
vous aimeriez oui et donc nous on a les
chiffres du cor quand même un du
gouvernement julie oui oui et c'est vrai
et donc nous on veut d'abord qu'on se
mette d'accord
voire même on veut dans cette conférence
de financement qu'il y ait des experts
indépendants
ça s'est déjà fait sur le comité
d'évaluation du cio des ados
d'entreprise on l'avait fait donc on
veut ça et ensuite qu'on veut qu'on
discute de tous les sujets et parmi tous
les sujets et à la question des recettes
du système des retraites
et là il ya un question du désengagement
de l'état 1 on sait que le corps a
pointé sa des engagements d'état et puis
à la question des dépenses et donc
regarder comment on peut on peut
financer avoir moyen et long passé à
deux autres sujets d'actualité juste une
question si elle le transport ça
s'améliore en région parisienne
puisqu'on disait tout à l'heure unsa
ratp a demandé à lever la grève pour
momentanément
est ce que vous y voyez le début de la
fin de la grève là en tout cas
aujourd'hui ça circule mieux
oui mais
faut le souhaiter pour les usagers je le
dis franchement faut le souhaiter pour
les usagers des transports franciliens
brigitte une question cette fois sur les
violences policières vous savez que
c'est un sujet qui revient avec ce qui
s'est passé dans les manifestations des
gilet jaune ou contre la réforme des
retraites oui à emmanuel macron a
demandé à christophe castaner le
ministre de l'intérieur de redéfinir la
déontologie dans la police est ce que
pour vous c'est une bonne réponse en
tout cas il faut que ça cesse et un
certain nombre de faits qui sont
inacceptables
on a vu un certain nombre d'image qui
sont pas frappé un homme en terre à
terre on sent glace et faire un croche
patte à une femme qui court tout ça est
inacceptable une dérive donc là willy
clairement il ya une dérive est en tout
cas vous savez la question des libertés
publiques c'est extrêmement important ça
implique quoi ça implique qu'il y ait
des forces de sécurité des forces de
l'ordre qu'ils puissent faire leur
boulot qu'ils soient respectées mais ça
implique que il y a un comportement
qu'ils soient irréprochables
l'allemand écoutez moi en tout cas je
trouve que depuis son arrivée je vais
être très franc je trouve que les choses
se sont dégradées et vous souhaitez
qu'il s'en aille
c'est pas moi qui les nomme non c'est
pas vous qui lui aussi avoir un edge
d'avoir des choses clairement
je trouve que il ya des pratiques là qui
se sont développés qui mérite d'être
largement recadrer et critiqué s'il faut
opérer le progrès d'hier mais voilà et
puis ça voulait dire
bon en tout cas il faut sans doute une
autre la laiterie doctrine de maintien
de l'ordre il faut sans doute
et puis l'autre côté il faut ça passait
par un changement de la boue passé à
savoir si vous savez je suis vraiment
pas un expert de ces morts étaient et
puis de l'autre côté je veux aussi dire
quand même que il faut aussi qu'il faut
aussi les policiers entendre que depuis
plus d'un an maintenant ils sont
quasiment tous les week-ends et donc ça
il faut en tenir compte parce qu'il ya
aussi beaucoup de mal être de ce côté là
une et je veux pas l'oublier une autre
question qui concerne l'emploi
oui et les chantiers les saint nazaire à
msc croisières commandes de paquebots
pour 2 milliards d'euros
des paquebots qui sont aussi pointés du
doigt car ils sont trop polluants vous
dans cette équation qu'est-ce que vous
privilégiez l'économie ou l'écologie
la sépaq boys sont à voile oui d'accord
d'accord ont failli pollue pas inaperçu
m c'est là qu'une pollution il faut je
pense qu'il faut les interdire de da
costa à venise mais c'est quand même
pour c'est quand même une bonne nouvelle
pour les chantiers de l'atlantique c2t
paquebot beaucoup moins polluant et donc
c'est très bien c'est comme certain
nombre de véhicules terrestres
ils sont pas totalement neutre sur le
plan carbone c'est sur cela mais ils
seront mieux que les autres et en tout
cas pour la région de saint-nazaire
c'est une excellente nouvelle région
vous connaissez puisque nous en sept
manches pour bien jouer
merci table merci brigitte il est
largement temps maintenant d'accueillir
les parlementaires qui attendent de vous
passer à la question
bonjour matile panneaux vous êtes député
la france a soumises du val de marne
vice-présidente du groupe à l'assemblée
nationale et bonsoir rené-paul savary
vous êtes sénateur les républicains de
la marne
on va commencer par matti de panneaux
premières questions sur le système à
points
justement oui j'avais une bonjour
monsieur bergé j'avais une question sur
le système de retraites à points parce
que pour nous tout le monde va être
perdant dans ce système là notamment
parce que les variables d'ajustement
dans system contraint financièrement sûr
on lâche des équilibres j'ai regardé mon
âge déquilibre par exemple pour moi qui
suis né en 1989
ça sera 66 ans et 2 mois et avec une
variable d'ajustement aussi autour de
cette valeur du pense que les belges
appellent la réforme de la retraite
tombola c'est à dire qu'on sait combien
de points en a mais on sait pas ce qu'on
aura à la fin et d'ailleurs les belges
ont réussi à la faire tomber j'espère
que nous aussi donc vous qui êtes
dirigeant syndical qui défendent les
droits des travailleurs êtes vous
sincèrement convaincu que la retraite
par points va améliorer la vie des gens
de notamment parce qu'il y a aussi deux
dents l'ouverture un système de
capitalisation sur le dos des individus
et pour le plus grand bonheur des fonds
de pension et connaissez vous un pays en
europe qui est mis en place le système à
points sans finir avec 15 % de taux de
pauvreté des seniors soit un taux deux
fois plus élevé que ce qui existe en
france aille à plusieurs questions tout
pauvreté et puis est-ce que ça va
améliorer la vie des gens sur le système
actuel nous le la progression qu'on a
fait sur le système universel moi je
parle de système universel parce que
finalement le point après c'est la
technique est pourquoi on veut un
système universel c'est que le constat
qu'on fait aujourd'hui est qu'on a fait
réforme après réforme 93 balladur la
réforme balladur qui a été extrêmement
violente sur le taux de remplacement dé
la revaloriser les retraites des
retraités ensuite 2003
c'a été
aussi une mesure parce qu'il fallait
sauver le système de retraite par
répartition qui était gravement menacée
qui si je le dis aujourd'hui en concert
quand 15% 2 du pib richesse nationale de
retraites si il n'y avait pas eu ces
réformes successives qu'on soit d'accord
ou pas et parfois on a été d'accord
parfois n'a pas été d'accord on serait à
19 % aujourd'hui ces petites pannes ou
la réforme le système universel que ça
va rendre les gens plus heureux que ceux
qui aujourd'hui sont sanctionnés dans le
système actuel
j'espère ce conte des basses pensions
parce qu'ils ont des des aléas de
carrière j'espère par exemple il ya un
exemple qui est souvent pris un tout
pour ses comptes notionnels mais là dans
le système actuel
dans le système actuel madame panneaux
et défend pas le système actuel en nous
on est pour le réformer aussi mais la
question de savoir qu'est ce qu'on nous
offre comme réforme allait parce que le
système actuel c'est quand même celui
qui a été assez solide finalement a été
stable parmi dans le système actuel ce
qui a été plus stable c'est quoi ces
leurs régimes complémentaires du privé
l'arrco et l'agirc ckoi l'arrco et
l'agirc
c'est un système par points c'est un
système par points sur lequel on a été
capable à certains moments de
revaloriser le point dû donner de la
majoration pour telle et telle situation
pour prendre en compte la situation de
salariés plus exposés etc
il a été très solide ce système il a été
très solide il n'a pas fait se
développer de la capitalisation la
capitulation voter ni de la pauvreté et
de la précarité
la capitalisation ça existe ça existe la
capitalisation aujourd'hui en système et
nous on souhaite que ce soit juste les
tâches supplémentaires et se soient
collectifs parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est
des salariés qui en sont exclus mais on
veut un système de répartition qui soit
solide
encore une fois c'est pas le système à
points ou pas à point qui compte c est
ce qu on veut un régime universel et moi
je souhaite un régime universel ça doit
passer par ici ça passerait ainsi
qu'alma point sébire et voilà rené paul
savary voulu épouser une question vous
sur le rôle des parlementaires dans ce
débat parce qu'on entend bien que
laurent berger est aux premières loges
en tant que représentant syndical mais
vous dites
juste qu'il va pas vraiment dans
l'histoire oui dans l'histoire puis vous
l'avez préciser je vais revenir un petit
peu sur vos propos s'ils sont tout à
fait juste et je les partage
le régime est à complémentaires agirc
arrco qui touche la plus grande malle
serait gérée d'ailleurs par les
partenaires sociaux fait les preuves de
son efficacité
c'est un régime par points mais qu'est
pas fondées comme le régime que l'on
nous propose avec 1h déquilibre c'est
bien ça la difficulté d'exister alors on
vous avait pas une bonne chose tout à
fait qu'il veuille venir aujourd'hui on
parle pas du crime mais aujourd'hui le
départ en retraite on est d'accord c'est
62 ans un âge légal le départ moyen
dation l'âge de départ moyen ses
soixante trois mois là et pour un
certain nombre de salariés
c'est beaucoup plus tard que ça
d'ailleurs certains salariés n'étaient
pas très contents qu'on avait fait
enlever l'âge pivot de la loi parce que
certains il y aurait gagné
oui d'autres repères vont perdre
attention aux canadiens votre casier en
question mais qu'il a donnée par rapport
au sentiment que vous ressentez de la
part du gouvernement parce que les
parlementaires eux ont l'impression
d'être maîtrisé méprisé pourquoi parce
que parce que derrière on a aucune étude
d'impact
on nous demande 23 ordonnance sur 64
arctique
du jamais vu on demande un gage de
confiance où tous les problèmes ne sont
pas résolus on a l'impression qu'en un
certain nombre de choses sur le tapis
par vous partenaires sociaux qui avait
déjà travaillé
avez vous pas le sentiment d'être un peu
en liberté surveillée et cette réforme
en fait n'était pas plutôt une réforme
financière qu'autre chose deux points
d'abord moi je suis pas pour qu'on se
doute repasse le rôle du parlement j'ai
jamais été pour ça sauf que vous avez
négocié pendant que les parlementaires
dans l'autre mais mais ça c'est pas des
décideurs mais c'est comme ça bah oui
mais
pas d'excusé mois ne pas vouloir
défendre vous le regrettez elle aurait
mieux valu reporter le débat
parlementaire et vous savez ce sujet là
est peut être sur la table
la parlementaire non mais ce sujet-là de
se donner davantage de temps il est sur
la table c'est retarder écouter dans un
pays qui c'est stérile c'est pas nous
c'est pas à moi de le décider mais ça
c'est ce que vous dites et redites que
le gouvernement donc de vrais airs et
angélique ça se discute mais ceux-ci
d'accord mais ça va être notre moi je ne
sais pas la responsabilité des
organisations syndicales et patronales
mais c'est dans une logique que les
organisations syndicales et patronales à
moment donné discute aussi un certain
nombre vous dit très bien avec les
représentants de l'état parce qu'on sera
plus tout seul puisque c'est pas que le
régime du privé il ya aussi de
l'employeur public ce qu'il doit assumer
sa part de responsabilité et qu'il fait
peu aujourd'hui donc là dessus c'est
clair après qu'elle ait le sentiment à
l'égard du gouvernement enfin je crois
être un de ceux qui depuis deux ans
maintenant a largement crier pour dire
la question de la démocratie sociale
n'est pas totalement respectée dans ce
pays et le rôle des organisations
syndicales et patronales n'est pas
totalement respectée il à celle les
caisses qui est pour les retraites
bah écoutez vous avez entendu avant le
11 décembre dire très clairement nous ne
voulons pas d'un d'une mesure d'âge qui
s'appliquerait de façon brutale et
aveugle et puis il ya eu la shq et après
les mobilisations ce que ce qu'on a dit
ce que d'autres ont fait peut-être
eh bien ça a permis de l'enlever et donc
c'est pas vous avez personne n'a moi
j'ai aucun d'eux j'ai renoncé à aucun de
mes principales à aucune de mes
ambitions
je ne vais pas le monopole des
négociations avec le gouvernement mais
bien sûr que non mais d'abord tout le
monde ait reçu tout le monde y va tout
le monde discute et après les l'idée
c'est d'essayer de se faire qu'en deux
temps là c'est ça le rôle d'une
organisation syndicale mathide panneaux
voulait parler aussi des femmes parce
que dans cette réforme le gouvernement
dit les femmes vont arrêter grande
gagnante exactement donc le gouvernement
répète à l'envi effectivement que les
femmes seraient les grandes gagnantes de
cette réforme des retraites en réalité
ça va être les grandes perdantes vous le
savez aujourd'hui c'est les 25
meilleures années dans le privé qui
compte ou les six derniers mois dans le
public
or là avec cette réforme le gouvernement
veut compter la carrière complète heures
vous le savez les femmes ont les
carrières les plus haché les plus
précaires elles sont payées 24% 2 mois
en moyenne
que les hommes et puis il ya tout ce
système aussi autour des enfants dont on
va parler juste après qui va souvent se
reporter vers l'homme puisque ça sera en
pourcentage et que l'homme
il ya eu malheureusement plus que les
femmes aujourd'hui et les femmes
divorcées n'auront plus le droit à la
pension de reversions donc ça fait quand
même beaucoup de choses qui font que les
femmes vont être perdante dans ce
système donc moi c'était la question que
je voulais vous poser est ce que vous
cautionnez un système qui va être aussi
défavorable aux femmes surtout que nous
comme on sait comme nous le portons par
exemple que si on faisait une égalité
réelle de salaires entre les femmes et
les hommes
on pourrait à court terme financer de
nouveau le retour de la retraite à 60
ans d'abord les inégalités dans le monde
du travail qui touche les femmes sont
scandaleuses
ce qui est plus scandaleux encore c'est
qu'on a tous les leviers aujourd'hui
juridique réglementaire pour les
combattre et qu'on n'y arrive pas et
qu'on n'y arrive pas et que les
organisations patronales les employeurs
ne le font pas mais que les
organisations syndicales n'y arrive pas
non plus à réduire ces inégalités
salariales
le deuxième élément c'est qu'au moment
de la retraite les femmes ou une
retraite du système actuel dont on a dit
aussi on a entendu c'est d'un étang
qu'il n'était pas si mal que ça il
fallait un peu là ménagé dans le système
actuel c'est plus de 30% de retraite en
moins pour les femmes +2 30% à mieux
vous dire non mais mais mais vous pouvez
le dire comme je peux dire que dans un
système universel la prise en compte des
aléas de carrière de la parentalité etc
permettra d'avoir potentiellement des
points supplémentaires sur les histoires
de par exemple de double aveugle au
droit suisse de droite à mondiaux mais
il faut faire en sorte que ces
améliorations
en tout cas si vous voulez par exemple
si vous prenez la prise en compte
vous parlez des six derniers mois des
primes dans un certain nombre de
secteurs de fonction publique c'est plus
favorable que des carrières linéaires
dont on sait que les femmes catégorie c
des fonctions publiques ont des
carrières linéaires les six derniers
mois de leur procure finalement pas
grand chose si vous intégrez les primes
boba vous savez des salariés catégorie c
ces salariés catégorie c au smic ou tout
proche du smic
on a quand même beaucoup tout proche du
smic et donc si vous prenez les primes
ça peut
c'est plus favorable juste sur les
droits familiaux moi je partage avec
vous que le pourcentage
aujourd'hui c'est c'est les hommes qui
en bénéficient forcément puisque ils ont
un meilleur salaire
nous on est pour une allocation
forfaitaire par enfant on est là pour la
caution forfaitaire par enfant qu'ils
soient alloués et qu'ils soient pas en
fonction du pourcentage de la pension
donc c'est c'est des choses qu'on va
pousser qu'on va continuer de pousser
sur lequel on se bat mais moi je veux
pas partir d'un constat qui dirait que
le système actuel serait bien parce qu
elle le futur l inverse de la réforme
alors systèmes existants trop il faut
les hommes et les femmes
eva ne va pas permettre à énormément de
femmes dans ce pays d'avoir une retraite
digne
d'ailleurs vous avez vu les
mobilisations notamment d'attac qui
chante cette chanson à cause de mâcon
qui montre bien que les femmes vont être
en première ligne parce qu'elles sont
les premières perdantes de s'être rené
paul savary jodoin s'ensuivent dessus
sur les droits fichier où justement les
5 % par enfant parce que celle ci c'est
une mesure qui est clair on comprend
mais vous dites attention il ya
peut-être quelque chose par rapport à
par rapport à l'actuelle mai
c'est vrai qu'il faudra faire des
simulations et senna de souvenirs parce
que les indices le système finalement il
est relativement jeune système est
généreux par rapport aux autres niveau
de vie moyen des retraités c'est quand
même 103 104 % par rapport au niveau des
moyens de ceux qui travaillent
demain on sait que dans les projections
et le nouveau calcul est calculée sur
les mêmes projections du comité
d'orientation des retraites ce sera plus
85%
donc je ne suis pas convaincu qu'il soit
plus généreux demain ce système parce
que il est quand même père fille il est
redoutable système de 2,2 système par
points avec l'âge déquilibre pourquoi
quand vous prenez l'article 9 il vous
dit on va revenir et on va comptabiliser
à l'achat du poids et même à sa revanche
on va le faire en indexant sur le voeu
de revenus moyens donc une mesure plus
généreuse que l'ex physique que ce qui
existe aujourd'hui et dans l'article 10
ont dit comment elle va on va le
financer avec l'âge des équilibres donc
faudra travailler plus pour pourvoir
prendre ces mesures
ce qui veut dire qu'à contrario si vous
prenez pas de mesures d'âge vous avez
des pensions plus faibles
donc vous avez mis le doigt dessus faut
être attentif à cet équilibre parce que
ça peut être complètement redoutable et
pour éviter de les confiance me
semble-t-il
il faudrait peut-être faire des
simulations on a les dispositifs qui le
permet alors et prendre le temps
nécessaire si on veut respecter les
discussions avec les partenaires sociaux
si vous voulez être respectée la
discussion le temps parlementaire le
sénat là dessus il a encore quelques
mois il est mal traitée mais moins bien
et que là encore mieux quand même que
l'assemblée nationale parce que c'est
dans quelques jours qui vont discuter
sans étude d'impact avec des ordonnances
et bien il serait temps de faire place à
des six malades on vous est impossible
avec voilà je suis d'accord on les
réclame depuis l'amour on réclame ces
simulations il faut les faire ce qu'il
faut ce qu'il faut faire comment
individuellement situation d'exception
chacun effectivement vous savez nous on
avait fait une enquête qui s'appelait
parlons retraite il ya un an et demi ce
qui était frappant c'est que les
salariés à 4-5 ans de la retraite
n'était pas capable de dire combien ils
allaient toucher au moment des retraites
non maintenant c'est vrai que le système
de liquidation unis sera une vingtaine
sont basses non non il avait va écouter
notre ce sera mieux avec le système non
je dis pas que ce sera on peut rêver que
ce soit plus lisible ce qui est sûr
c'est qu'il faut des études d'impact
il faut surtout des simulations ça on le
demande avec des cas types et c'est
pourquoi ça ne vient pas mais je crois
je crois enfin c'est que ces fouilles
inscrit oui enfin ça c'est ce qu'on
croit le système redistributif il ya
vraiment des gens n'ont rien fait alors
mais parce que je crois que il ya eu
beaucoup de cafouillages de la part du
gouvernement je les dis et je les ai
répétés et donc c'est pour ça qu'il faut
maintenant mettre cartes sur table y
compris sur les besoins de financement
du système de retraites après sur les
enfants moi je crois que le système qui
fait que c'était à partir de trois
enfants est injuste que c'est logique
que ce soit dès le premier enfant et que
ce soit forfaitaire il faudra aussi
faire des études faire des impositions
c'est là dessus tout à fait se seraient
musclées forfaitaire vous étiez toujours
sur ceux devenus si vous permettez
simplement et rapidement
vous avez proposé une conférence des
financeurs du va voir les rues du
financement complément du financement
pourquoi vous proposez pas une
conférence du bien-être au travail pour
prendre en compte la pénibilité l'emploi
des seniors le regard nouveau qu'il faut
dans ma langue c'est tout ce qu'on voit
pas ce que fait une conférence fort de
mes neuf apparaîtra fait ça fait un an
sur une négociation ou alors au
gouvernement de prendre de prendre des
décisions sur la qualité de vie au
travail
ça c'est un axe extrêmement important
pour nous et deuxièmement en même temps
ou
depuis le début janvier il y a des
discussions où toutes les organisations
syndicales et patronales participent sur
la pénibilité l'emploi des seniors bien
les fans carrière la sélection des
transitions pour les éternels son public
alors y est aussi dans la vie aussi dans
la réforme la promesse de retraite qui
ne serait pas en dessous de 1000 euros
par mois et là vous avez une question de
type de panneau cédez pas là dessus moi
c'était sur les questions de démocratie
plutôt d'accord si vous préférez mais
vous me disiez tout à l'heure vous
disiez le rôle d'organisme des
organisations syndicales n'est pas
respectée aujourd'hui vous parliez tout
à l'heure d'un déménageur qui par
exemple sur le critère de pénibilité de
charges lourdes aujourd'hui plus ces
critères de pénibilité puisque le
gouvernement emmanuel macron ont
commencé le quinquennat en supprimant
quatre critères de pin de pénibilité
pardon pour les travailleurs il ya aussi
eu l'épisode de la réforme de
l'assurance du chômage ou le
gouvernement excusez-moi l'expression
mais c'est assis sur les syndicats en
dessinant lui même et en excluant des
centaines de milliers de personnes de
l'indemnisation chômage
aujourd'hui on est dans une situation où
la majorité de la population dit qu'elle
est opposée à cette réforme des
retraites mais le gouvernement a l'air
décidé à passer en force donc ma
question était la suivante croyez vous
encore en ce gouvernement alors qu'ils
ne respectent aucun des corps
intermédiaires et notamment les
syndicats qu'il méprise et refuse
d'écouter le peuple mais là c'est une
organisation syndicale vous savez moi
j'étais délégué du personnel dans
l'association dans laquelle je
travaillais je ne choisissait pas mon
directeur et donc mon interlocuteur
comme délégué du personnel c'était mon
directeur et je faisais avec aujourd'hui
un responsable syndical dans ce pays
il fait avec ce que le peuple a élu pas
moi qui les ai vus c'est le peuple le
peuple est souverain
vous êtes d'accord avec ça oui la
démocratie c'est pas moi qui vais dire
l'inversé matière mais en démocratie
ceux qui sont élus ils assument un
mandat à l'organe pas un blanc-seing
pour qu'il est bien sûr c'est un blanc
seing année un chèque en blanc etc
mais il assume un mandat et que moi je
crois dans une démocratie que il faut
essayer par tous les moyens de
convaincre quand on porte des idées
c'est ce que fait la cfdt mais elle
choisit pas la question n'est pas la
confiance ou pas la confiance là que la
question allait la qualité de la
proposition qu'on est capable de faire
et le rapport de forces qu'on est
capable de me
et c'est comme ça que la cfdt à j ai
donc on n'a eu de cesse de répéter qu'il
fallait davantage de place aux
organisations syndicales et au dialogue
social
on a combattu la réforme de l'assurance
chômage on va dans les mois à venir de
montrer très concrètement comment ça
s'applique pour les demandeurs d'emploi
c'est extrêmement brutal c'est moi même
qui ai eu des termes assez très souvent
perdu son chemin mais bien sûr on a
perdu et donc en gros c'est donc une
grosse déception pour vous j'ai dit oui
et c'est pour ça que les organismes
syndicales ne peuvent pas se permettre
de perdre à chaque fois
et donc là sur la peau finalement on
perdrait pas non ce que j'ai dit d'abord
sur l'âge pivot point des salariés très
concrets qui nous ont écrit que je
connais que j'ai rencontré à partir de
2022 ils n'auront pas cet âge pivot
maintenant oui ça nous met sous pression
je les ai dit c'est une part de risque
mais je préfère prendre cette part de
risque y compris de se faire attaquer
plutôt que de laisser les salariés dans
les prochaines années partir plus tard à
la retraite alors que c'est totalement
restions passage l'idée d'un référendum
sur les retraites vous dit non on oublie
tout pourquoi pas d'abord je dis bon
courage pour poser la question mais mais
sinon bon écoutez moi je pense que je
pense qu'on devrait être beaucoup plus
mature dans notre pays et qu'on devrait
être capable de regarder où sont les
risques où sont les opportunités et
d'essayer de passer après ces
gouvernements décident elles sont
responsables les 1000 euros donc c'est
vous rené paul savary qui vous vie en
parler 1000 euros minimum de retraite
oui sur un minimum contributif 1 quand
on lit bien la loi on voit bien que ce
minimum sera fondée sur une durée alors
que dans le système par points te répond
il y aura peut être du mal aimé
une notion de durée qui revient comme un
certain nombre de domaines et c'est 105
116 mois donc 43 ans de carrière
complète avec des cotisations minimum à
hauteur du smic pour avoir les 1000
euros et qu'ils vont s'étaler sur un
certain nombre d'années
c'est par rapport au minimum contributif
actuellement 40 à 50 euros
supplémentaires
donc effectivement il ya travaillé et
dans tous les éléments les droits
familiaux attention c'est à mon avis
quand on fera les expertises - gagnant
avec les 1 2 3 enfants que ce qui existe
actuellement
derrière dans l'art version 70% de
reversions en sachant qu'il ya de moins
en moins de mariages et de plus en plus
de divorces et en conséquence il y aura
de moins en moins de réversion puisque
quand il ya du vent donc derrière tous
ces droits sociaux vous devez y
êtes-vous partenaires sociaux
particulièrement attentifs et on voit
bien qu'il ya une volonté de grignoter à
chaque fois c'est la raison pour
laquelle il faut une vigilance accrue
hier avoir arrêté est ce que cette
volonté vous savez sur la réversion la
proposition de la cfdt c'est que ça
concerne tous les couples tous les
couples est pas forcé pas que ces mêmes
on pourra imaginer qu'on appelle union
libre
on pense que ça devrait concerner tous
les couples qui l'ont société a donné
vécu ensemble ça a beaucoup de
résistance stature et peut-être plus
dans vos rangs que dans d'autres et donc
là dessus on est extrêmement clair après
sur les je ne suis pas sûr et je me suis
reprise dans l'oeuf d'être seul au
minimum sur du le minimum contributif
sur le minimum contributif c'est la cfdt
l'a porté depuis 10 ans 15 ans on porte
cette idée de revalorisation du minimum
contributif mille euros c'est en dessous
du seuil de pauvreté lance une personne
qui a milk mille et quelques euros et
donc c'est insuffisant par ses soins
voilà pourquoi dans les semaines à venir
on va se battre pour que l'on aille bien
au delà de 1000 euros maintenant une
réflexion courte pour une réponse courte
questions très précises questions
courtes sur la conférence de financement
parce que vous savez aujourd'hui il n'y
a pas de problème entente et de
financement du système des retraites il
existerait beaucoup de pistes notamment
l'augmentation de 1% des salaires ça
ramènerait 2 5 milliards d'euros dans
les caisses
de retraite mais ces pistes sont
aujourd'hui toutes refusées alors à quoi
bon accepter une conférence de finances
alors puisque les sommes seront
plafonnées à 14%
et est ce que vous n'avez pas peur de
vous retrouver enfermé dans un modèle
dans lequel les variables d'ajustement
seront les gens énormément d'argent dans
notre pays
j'avais dit cours réponses courtes pour
la réponse courte aux tempes ou si c'est
une prise de risque mais je préfère
plutôt que les salariés soient soumis
dès 2022 à partir 4 mois huit mois 12
mois à travailler à partir plus tard en
retraite puis dernier point je le dis
14%
si notre pays continue à créer de la
richesse ça se discute c'est pas un
chiffre un barrière on peut en discuter
mais ce qui est sûr c'est que dans le
pays il faut qu'on discute aussi de la
part qu'on consacre à la petite enfance
qu'on consacre à la lutte contre la
pauvreté et aux retraités et donc aux
retraites mais aujourd'hui il ya 20% des
enfants qui sont en situation de
pauvreté aussi dans le pays bien et donc
ça veut dire que c'est des choix qu'il
faut dire que cette approche de la
fiscalité c'est des sujets zone m et il
répondu pour laurent berger au très
courte sur la gouvernance ou bien qu'un
éloignement des grosses grosses
quantités cela éloigne toujours de la
proximité et vous serez associés à la
gouvernance
que pensez vous de la place du corps le
comité d'orientation des retraites qui a
fait quand même preuve juste voilà une
instance eux très paritaire ce qui dans
le projet doit être une coquille vide
réponse je devrais t'en la gouvernance
on pense que le corps actuel ou rénové
on verra où a enrichi mais le corps il a
fait la démonstration de son
impertinence depuis maintenant
nombreuses années il n'y a pas de raison
d'en lever cette idée que des
interlocuteurs du monde syndical
patronal des élus se confrontent avec
des experts pour essayer de regarder
qu'il ya six ans une retraite merci rené
paul savary merci matip panneaux d'être
venu sur le plateau d'auditions
publiques et maintenant on arrive à la
partie d'yves thréard et organiste
figaro qui est avec nous ce soir
évidemment comme tous les lundis pour
vous poser ses questions
bonjour yves bot soit francis bonsoir
c'est mieux vous avez raison oui bonsoir
laurent berger alors je vous ai écouté
les tient à quai au début quand même un
coq qui était question d intrusion chez
vous il ya eu d'autres intrusion d'un
théâtre alors que le président de la
république assistaient à un spectacle on
a appris ce soir que
une responsable de la cgt confédéral
appelait à couper le courant à l'elysée
l'acte 2 de ce quinquennat devait être
celui de l'apaisement
est-ce qu'on n'est pas parti dans
l'embrasement la dette inquiète keane
qui ne serait pas inquiet dans le climat
dans lequel nous évoluons tous en ce
moment donc moi j'en appelle à
l'apaisement d'ailleurs il y aura une
annonce de cet acte ii ou pas ça
changerait pas grand chose j'en appelle
à une forme d'apaisement ckoi
l'apaisement c'est pas médecin mouchoir
par dessus ses convictions et ses
principes parmi ces valeurs partager ses
valeurs pardon c'est de 2,2 dire voilà
on est dans une démocratie
maintenant on s'écoute un peu plus les
uns et les autres on confronte on
confronte des idées pas des slogans des
idées parce que j'en attends beaucoup de
slogans mois il faut regarder fond des
choses il faut creuser un peu des sujets
et là on est aujourd'hui dans une
logique d'affrontement
le tout le monde en parle une part de
responsabilité sans doute mais aussi
d'ailleurs n'en savez vous par exemple
vous avez toujours été l'homme du
dialogue vous appeler au dialogue
est ce que finalement c'est pas votre
échec ça aussi d'une certaine façon côté
non même si c'est politique vous savez
le quand on regarde les sondages
d'opinion qui sortent en ce moment et
notamment sow sur les acteurs le taux de
défiance à l'égard d'autres
organisations syndicales ces 65 % le
taux de défiance à l'égard de l'exécutif
c'est 65 % le taux de défiance à l'égard
des partis politiques d'opposition c'est
75% le taux de défiance à l'égard de la
cfdt
c'est 50 et 2 je crois que c'est 52%
c'est pas un faux - oui enfin c'est pas
glorieux non plus mais ce que je veux
dire c'est que vous allez bien c'est je
réponds à votre question excusez moi par
ce biais là est-ce que c'est l'échec de
la cbt non puisque c'est on est ce on
est l'acteur aujourd'hui dans ce dans le
climat actuel dans lequel les français
ont le plus confiance qui ont le moins
de défiance si vous préférez mais c'est
extrêmement important
abc un mouvement qui est toujours
soutenu par les français oui oui bien
sûr mais parce que la poésie soderbergh
opinion là mais mais mais parce que mais
encore une fois je veux qu'on soit très
clair la cfdt elle ne dit pas que le
projet de loi tel qu'il est et celui de
la cfdt
pas du tout on va il ya plein de points
sur lesquels il ya des choses à changer
mais ce que je dis c'est que dans le
climat actuel
on aurait tous intérêt à être davantage
plutôt que dans des actions de ce
yp telle qu'on a subi aujourd'hui et
vendredi on ferait mieux de se parler un
peu plus correctement et déposer des
idées plutôt que d'opposer des slogans
aux uns aux autres est ce qu'on n'est
pas dans un climat aussi ou en fait on
veut la tête on veut couper la tête du
président de la république
oui mais le lire que ceux qui sont
rentrés dans le théâtre l'autre jour
voulez ça bah je sais pas j'ai crié ça
mais ce qui est sûr mais c'est pas
acceptable
je la connais je trouve ça désespérant
mais ce qui est sûr c'est que on est
dans une situation où il faut que chacun
s'interroge sur ce qu'il a joué ou pas
joué ces derniers temps et je t'assure
gouvernement ça s'adresse à tout le
monde y compris présents dans le public
oui bien c'est le médian une
responsabilité bien sûr les médias les
réseaux sociaux voilà tu veux dire mon
temps mais vous savez je vais vous
prendre un exemple
vendredi intrusion osseja cvt crachats
violence verbale et physique
la cfdt elle à communiquer là dessus par
mon intermédiaire par un seul tweet
parce que ce qui était rentré montré sur
des vidéos des petites portions de vidéo
des extraits ce qui s'était passé mais
donc nous on aura peut-être pas
communiquer autrement on est on est on a
communiqué on n'a rien dit d'autre
pendant tout le week-end
il ya une rare relativisme
extraordinaire on y z'ont les vidéos
c'est plutôt sympa et c'est d'abord je
dis à ceux qui disent ça donnez moi
votre adresse puis on va se pointer à 30
ou 40 puis on va aller faire un peu la
fiesta chez vous et puis deuxièmement
ensuite on a vu tout le film tout ce qui
s'est passé est là il y avait des
violences si chacun d'entre nous
commencent par ne pas accepter les
violences
deuxièmement d'essayer de poser de poser
des choses avec rigueur et posément
troisièmement de respecter ses
interlocuteurs même quand on n'est pas
d'accord
est ce que vous m'avez entendue depuis
le début de cet épisode dire le mal de
quiconque
non alors justement par contre on va
revenir un peu sur les retraites n'est
pas sur le contenu sur la forme alors
l'âge pivot a été provisoirement retiré
rien été créé dans le texte que c'est
provisoire d'accord est d'accord mais
c'est pas ne s'est pas anecdotique pour
les salaires etc est un observateur
avisé du monde syndical a écrit dans le
figaro il n'y a pas très longtemps
le boss c'est laurent berger parce que
grâce à lui bien l'âge pivot a été
retiré vous êtes le boss aujourd'hui non
mais ce serait d'avoir un ce serait très
mal me connaître
moi vous savez je respire un peu plus de
tranquillité que de la période
et deuxièmement vainqueur non vous avez
les vainqueurs de cet âge pivot qui est
retiré
ouais ce sont les travailleurs concernés
ce sont eux qui vont ceux qui partaient
par exemple en 2024 au hasard mais
qu'elle est de voir travailler une année
supplémentaire et donc moi je sais pas
comme ça et puis les choses d'abord deux
syndicats et c'est quelque chose de
collectif et deuxièmement ça doit être
utile sur la conférence de financement
le premier ministre a très bien poser
les choses c'est très clair pas
d'augmentation des cotisations
pas de baisse des pensions
et si vous partenaires sociaux vous
trouvez pas la solution de financement
peut-être le retour de la spin ans et
d'y passer un sale ici je prendrai mes
responsabilités
c'est autre chose que peut-être la wii
aujourd'hui voir où on sait ce que ça
veut dire
bah ça veut pas forcément dire ça parce
qu'on pourra peut-être faire des
propositions intelligentes si jamais on
se met pas d'accord il ya peut-être des
choses à apprendre qu'ils yara la
question de l'utilisation des réserves
et à la question vous savez de ses
cotisations en moins sur les trois
passes on peut regarder ça il ya la
question de dévolution des cotisations
de un secteur à un autre
et puis il ya la question aussi de
l'emploi des seniors 2 le 10 6 euros il
ya 40% des gens qui liquident leur
retraite avant l'argent non qui
liquident leur retraite légale parce que
ils sont pas en emploi soit chômage la
maladie
il y aurait là si on améliore l'emploi
si on en met your l'emploi des seniors
on résout une partie de la
responsabilité des entreprises sans
oreilles bien sûr et ils sont aussi
contraints de les taxes que ça soit
moins facile de se séparer de seniors
alors il est à ça à sa responsabilité en
tant qu'employé qu'est ce que vous
répondez à la marine le pen quand elle
vous traite d'idiots utiles du
gouvernement dans cette réforme du bac
pro 10 mhz mais je vous avez d'abord se
faire insulter par marine le pen c'est
peut-être la seule chose qui me dérange
pas est ce que c'est vraiment oui de la
violence bah c'est pas très étonnant de
la part du rassemblement national et
madame le pen
deuxièmement je crois que madame le pen
elle
est-ce que d'une chose c'est de
prospérer sur le chaos sur le chaos et
sur la recherche de boucs émissaires
voilà et c'est pas étonnant que la cfdt
la dérange parce que la cfdt elle porte
un modèle de société qui est tout autre
que celui de madame le pen et donc ça me
laisse assez de glace on va parler de
vous alors aux appareils vous puisque
vous êtes à la tête de ce syndicat qui
est le premier syndicat de france privé
et public confondus depuis 2012 où il ya
des élections normalement en 2022 à cfdt
cfdt
oui parce que parce que vous serez
candidat votre réélection c'est trop tôt
pour le dire je ne sais pas deux
prédécesseurs n'ont qu'à ouvrir vos deux
prédécesseurs ont fait dix ans
bah voilà eh ben on verra vous ferez
flamande à puce vous je sais pas est ce
qu'on fait est ce que contexte actuel
vous n'en ferez ce que la cfdt c'est
vous savez c'est une agression
collective il ya beaucoup de gens
comprennent talent des femmes des hommes
parce qu'aujourd'hui on a nos directions
de notre direction
ctt paritaire totalement en mixte
égalité et donc il ya des femmes des
hommes qui ont du talent et donc on
verra
c'est trop tôt pour lui alors et puis
mais ce qui est sûr c'est que là
le la durée de dix ans plus ou moins
quelques années encore elle est à peu
près d'arlon s'applique comme règle
depuis que vous êtes en fonction vous
avez connu trois présidents de la
république est ce que monsieur macron on
a eu pensons penser que vous pensiez
peut-être l'était le plus hermétique de
tous d'abord j'en ai connu que deux
parce qu'avant c'était françois scherr
avec mon chéri
ils sont pas ils sont vraiment pas
pareil que les uns et les autres
alors non mais ce qui est sûr c'est que
je les dis le début de ce quinquennat il
a quand même été et ça même été
théorisée par certains de ses
collaborateurs comme étant celui où il
faut on n'avait pas besoin finalement
des acteurs sociaux et et en fait on
s'aperçoit qu'il revienne par la fenêtre
c'est réparé ça c'est tsariste compliqué
mais c'est le rôle d'une organisation
syndicale pourquoi c'est une association
mais je crois que notre pays il est pas
il attend maintenant pourquoi c'est
compliqué avec emmanuel macron c'est ça
la question ne s'est pas c'est compliqué
je crois parce que le contexte il pousse
à dos les sentiments qu'il y aurait un
homme ou une femme providentiel qui
devrait arriver et tout sera réglé ça
marche pas comme ça il faut de la
démocratie sociale que ces désagréments
syndicales mais aussi des associations
c'est ce qu'on a fait avec ce pacte du
pouvoir de vivre qui va fêter ses 1 an 5
à 10 secondes et qu'il ya beaucoup de
cure oui ou non est ce que vous êtes
optimiste pour le dialogue social à
l'avenir dans ce pays
je suis mobilisé et mon optimisme je ne
sais pas en tout cas je suis très
mobilisés parce que je crois pas qu'on
avancera sans dialogue social sont
démocratie sociale merci merci merci
laurent berger d'être venu dans audition
publique merci d'avoir accepté de
débattre et de répondre à nos questions
n'oubliez pas que vous pouvez retrouver
cette émission à 23h sur lcp et public
sénat sur figaro live également audition
publique revient lundi prochain à 19h
bonne soirée merci
[Musique]